advice from anthony robbins on finding  your passion as seen in zoo go 101 live  with passion there is no greatness  without a passion to be great whether  it's the aspiration of an athlete or an  artist a scientist a parent or business  person people are not lazy they simply  have impotent goals that is goals that  do not inspire them in life you need  either inspiration or desperation one  reason so few of us achieve what we  truly want is that we never direct our  focus we never concentrate our power  most people dobble their way through  life never decided to master anything in  particular we can change our lives we  can do have and be exactly what we wish  to learn more check out Zuger 101 in the  link below